your service will be changed last minute
for example you have to come to work earlier
or you suddenly have to work other hours
that is not allowed just like that and that is what this video is about
it has happened to everyone once
you will be 1 day before you start
or maybe 1 few hours or that you are going to start
patted by your employer with
if you can come to work other times
you can start a little later or you have to stay longer
but how exactly does that work
employer may not just ask you this
you have 1 call period of 4 days
in the case of some collective labor agreements 24 hours
within these 4 days or 24 hours
your service may no longer be changed
but what if this happens anyway
then you are entitled to your original service
that you were going to work
plus any additional number of hours
so if you had to start at 9 o'clock
and had to stop at 5 o'clock
and you have to work longer until 7 and start later
for example start at noon
So you have the right to be paid from 9 to V7
1 problem in the employer's schedule
is not simply your problem